it was totally humiliating Savannah
Guthrie stopped by The Ellen Show and
opened up about playing tennis against
Roger Federer for charity okay and
that's Bill gay okay yeah and I can't it
was I kept missing the ball and they
they were miked and Rogers like Savannah
oh wow stop looking at me and start
looking at the ball in 2017 the Today
Show co-anchor revealed to Ellen that
she had a harmless crush on the tennis
pro there's someone you're obsessed with
and I mean like you're obsessed with him
right it's a problem and the 46 year old
journalist said that it was that chat
that got her the invite to the
tournament the fact that you talked
about my obsession with Roger really put
it into the mainstream and so it got
back to Roger and so his people called
me and said would you like to play in
this celebrity tennis tournament with
him which I hadn't even met him
of course I was like yes one thing I'm
not very good at tennis mm-hmm and I was
I was hoping his agent would be like oh
well that's all right it's the charity
you don't need to be good he was like oh
well my colleague will be in he can
Scout you on Monday I had to go play
tennis like I had to audition oh wow
yeah and I hadn't played since tennis
camp so but I guess whatever I made it
and decided to do it and then I was
really bad at it and while she may not
have killed it on the tennis court she
did enjoy meeting her crush she was
really nice he's like oh I feel like I
know you
oh that's so sweet so he lived up to
your expectations yes and exceeded them
I would like him to be on the show so if
this will get back to you Roger I would
like you to be on the show I I could be
there too if you want I just say Jimmy
now we're late I kind of know him now oh
yeah sure yeah okay then you should be
here for sure
Savannah also revealed where she keeps
the life-size cardboard cutout of Roger
that Ellen gifted her in 2017 we have a
house upstate and there we have a bar in
the basement we call the bomb shelter
and Roger is the bartender Oh
and it's really funny because he's the
basement so it's kind of dark and people
like visit and they're like well yeah
you know it's kind of creepy it is kind
of creepy he's shirtless yeah so it's
yeah
actually Jenna Bush came over and had a
couple of too many and she broke Rogers
arm oh yeah we taped them back together
cuz I can give you another one no no
[Music]
[Applause]